tonight a man is in custody following a
weekend shooting in front of the
hawaiian marketplace one person died two
others were injured
and brian one of those shots came out of
the incident with quite a scary story of
how it all went down
8 news now reporter sally jaramillo
spoke with him with the victim and has
more tonight sally
brian and denise nolan newberry says
he's happy he's
alive and tonight along with his wild
story to tell
he also has a message for metro
i'm grateful i mean the cops handle the
great
around 3 a.m sunday police say
25-year-old malik frost
opened fire in front of the hawaiian
marketplace leaving one person dead
and two injured one of those injured was
nolan newberry
who works at vegas inc on the las vegas
strip i was tattooing about the
set up to do a little smiley face tattoo
on this girl and uh
tourists are running by a guy runs
inside of the shop and he's like there's
a gunman outside
newberry recalls seeing a female
security guard take off running
his first instinct i run outside to get
you know
to give some help he also said others
wanted to help
and they all set out to catch the gunman
he's pulling out a gun
he's flailing around i just found out
from the security body cam video that
he got hit in the head with a rock as
for newberry i feel a rock
jump up into my leg i'm thinking this is
no way this is what a bullet feels like
newberry said after he was shot it
didn't take long for police to apprehend
frost
i go back inside and tell everybody
barricade in the back that it's safe
and today he said it's business as usual
and went back to work
i always try to you know do my part and
get involved
you know be the son my parents race
tonight his message to metro police
heroes thank you guys very much you uh
handle people on their worst day every
day and
we appreciate you as for malik frost
he's
he is being held at the clark county
detention center without bail he is
expected to be back in court
on wednesday morning reporting live
sally jaramillo 8 news now